字幕: Kelly Dao
校正: Emi Atarashi
皆さん こんにちは
高橋勇造と申します
突然ですが 皆さんは
普段 生活を送る中で
やりたいことをしていますか
私は仕事を通して
やりたいことをしています
でも 今まで 12年間
自分は将来 何をやりたいんだろうって
小学校の６年生の卒業式から
ずっと モヤモヤと悩んでいました
今から考えると
やりたいことを仕事にするとか
やりたいことを見つける
そういったことに
そこまで とらわれなくても
いいのかなと思っています
でも もし やりたいことを見つけたいという風に
思っている方がいましたら
今日の話が参考になれば
うれしいです
今 認定NPO法人 Kacotam っていう団体を
運営しています
私が一般企業に入社するのと同時に
児童養護施設の子どもと
学習を通して関わるボランティアを始めました
その後 Kacotam っていう団体を立ち上げて
途中で会社を辞めて
そして 今は Kacotam を運営しています
具体的にどんなことを
やっているかと言いますと
児童養護施設や
母子生活支援施設に訪問して
子どもたちと
学習を通して関わっています
また ひとり親家庭や
生活保護世帯の子どもたちを対象にした
学習支援も行っています
それ以外に
将来就きたい職業とか
興味のある職業に就いている方に
お話を聞きに行ったりとか
子どもたちがやりたいと思ったことを実現する
サポートをしたりしています
この写真は 巨大折り鶴を折りたい
その子と一緒に
巨大折り鶴を折った時の
写真になっています
やりたいこと それは
自分の中にそのやりたいのヒントが
隠されているというふうに思います
外に何かを求めるのではなくて
自分の中です
そのやりたいのヒントは
価値観、興味関心、心地良さ
この３つの視点から 因数分解していくと
自分が見えてきます
今日は３つの方法を
ご紹介したいと思います
１つは 経験に対する自分の感情を
大事にするということです
今までも これからも
さまざまな経験をすると思います
その１つ１つの経験に対して
自分はどのような感情を抱いたのか
そこにヒントが隠されています
例えば
私が大学３年生の頃に
大学新聞で 同じ学年の子が起業した
というような記事を読みました
そのときに
ワクワクした感情と
うらやましいな っていう風に
思う感情が出てきました
また 虐待がニュースで取り上げられるたびに
むなしさであったりとか
憤りというのを感じていました
それは今も同じです
そういうふうに ちょっとした経験に対して
自分はどんな感情を抱いたのか
それを積み上げていくと
やりたいことのヒントが そこに隠されています
次に 自分はどんなことに興味を持っていたのか
ということを振り返るということです
私は 小学生の時にミニ四駆
中学生の時は釣り
そして高校生の時は
空手をやっていました
今日は ミニ四駆について
少しお話ししたいと思います
小学校５年生 ６年生の時に
ちょうど ミニ四駆が流行っていました
その頃の生活っていうのは
学校から帰ってきて
家から友達の家に行って
ミニ四駆やって
また学校に行って また帰ってきて
またミニ四駆やって
そういった生活を送っていました
そういった生活を送っていくと
もっとミニ四駆をやりたい
もっとミニ四駆をいじりたい
そういう風に 思いが募りました
そこで 思いつきました
学校で ミニ四駆クラブを作ればいいんじゃね
っていう風に思いました
それから仲間を集めて
学校の先生にお願いをして
ミニ四駆クラブを作りました
そしたら 思っていた以上に
先生が協力してくれて
息子さんのコースを わざわざ
学校に持ってきてくれました
そういう風に ミニ四駆自体も
楽しかったんですけども
仲間が集まって
応援してくれる存在がいて
そういう風に
クラブとして出来上がっていく
その過程にも すごく 楽しさや居心地の良さ
っていうのを感じていました
そういう風に 自分の興味関心を
深めたりとか 広げたりする
そういった過程にも
新しい興味関心であったりとか
心地よさが隠されています
次に どんな人に影響受けたのか
ということを振り返るということです
私は大学の先生と
家庭教師で関わっていた家族に
すごく影響を受けました
今日は 大学の先生とのお話を
したいと思います
私が大学４年生の時に
卒業研究で
今 自分が大事にしている
自分で考えて行動すること
自分で考えて行動することを楽しむということ
を気づかされました
私が「今日こんなことをやろうと
思ってるんですけども どうですかね」
っていう風に言うと
先生は
「あぁ いいね やってみたら」
っていう風に
こう 一歩踏み出す
後押しをしてくれたりとか
うまくいかないときは
ヒントを出してくれたりして
自分で考えて行動する機会を
たくさん用意してくれていたように思います
そういう風に
自分はどんな人に影響を受けて
その人がどんな人なのか
そこを振り返ってみると
自分では気づかない価値観であったりとか
興味関心が そこに隠されています
今日は３つの方法をご紹介しました
経験に対する自分の感情を
大事にするということ
２つ目に 自分はどんなことに
興味を持っていたのか
そして３つ目に
どんな人に影響を受けたのか
そこを振り返ると
やりたいのヒントが隠されています
改めて 皆さんにお伝えしたいと思います
自己実現のあり方ってのは
みんな違います
やりたいことを仕事にする
っていうこともありますし
やりたいことは ボランティアや
趣味を通して実現するという人もいます
また そもそも
やりたいことって何だろうっていう風に
とらわれなくてもいいかもしれません
でも もし やりたいことを見つけたい
そういった方がいましたら
今日の話が
参考になればうれしいです
ありがとうございました